les bâtiments que vous voyez sont ceux
du lycée agricole de laval
là on forme les futurs agriculteurs et
les techniciens agricoles
le lycée berges actuellement 250 élèves
recrutés au niveau de la quatrième ou de
la seconde donc de 13 à 16 ans ce
recrutement s'adresse bien sûr en
particulier aux fils d'agriculteur mais
les autres candidatures ne sont pas
exclues un enseignement général et
dispensés dans ses salles de cours
pourtant une large place est laissée aux
travaux pratiques à cet effet les lycées
agricoles dispose entre autres de
laboratoire de chimie physique de
sciences naturelles
les élèves peuvent accéder à l'un ou
l'autre de deux cycles d'études d'abord
le cycle long aboutissant au brevet de
technicien agricole et au brevet de
technicien supérieur
le cycle moyen lui permet d'obtenir le
brevet d'enseignement agricole ou le
brevet d'agent technique
l'enseignement se poursuivit damman sur
le terrain en l'occurrence ici un
domaine agricole de 40 hectares malgré
le grand air la nature incitant à la
détente
les élèves gardent tout leur sérieux et
leur désir d'apprendre d'apprendre et ce
n'est pas facile à faire de beaux
sillons bien victime rien n'est donc
laissé au hasard par les éducateurs car
le métier gricole est un métier
difficile qui demande de nos jours des
connaissances générales techniques et
économiques des tanks